did you know that a simple speaker
completely transformed modern music
festivals affecting everything from
sound quality Festival layout and stage
design when I first heard vertical line
array I knew as soon as I heard it that
that was the way of the future
this is Dave he's a sound engineer and
sound system designer who's worked on
festivals before and after this change
and has provided audio for Coachella
since 2001. how did this speaker affect
audio quality ideally you'd only want
one speaker to cover an area but for
concerts you need multiple what do we do
when you have more than one speaker
covering an area there's two different
basic theories or concepts on ways to do
that one is point source with point
source each speaker acts independently
creating multiple sound waves that hit
the audience at different times like a
firework or shower head configuration
this creates inconsistent sound meaning
you'd hear the music very differently if
you stand here versus here so how do we
fix that with a line array we have a
speaker and instead of putting one
alongside of it we put another one above
it and below it and above it and above
it now as you walk across the horizontal
domain walk across side to side you only
hear one speaker if you were to go up
and down you'd hear the problems but
line arrays pile all the problems up
where we hear them least so what does it
sound like if you were to walk across a
field with a point source Speaker versus
a line array
what we're hearing is called a comb
filtering effect when interference
causes the same sound to be heard with a
very small time delay between signals
this is the type of audio interference
we'd hear in a point source system
fairly beamy sounding kind of hot spot
in the middle and Fades on the left and
Fades on the right what if we take that
same thing we can figure them
into a line
but look what happens vertically
that's what lion arrays do they allow
you to walk side by side and have a very
smooth sound very similar to a single
driver because in the horizontal domain
should we slice it that's all we have
lineries may sound clear and more evenly
spread so that almost anywhere you stand
the show sounds similar first concert I
heard it it sounded like the PA was
closer than it physically looked it was
kind of uh messing with my mind it was
how can it sound so close and look so
far I'd never heard anything like that
before how did line arrays help create
today's Festival layout if we have
multiple stages on a festival ground one
of the big challenges is preventing
sound from this stage from affecting
this stage with the use of laser
rangefinders 3D mapping and precise
angling sound designers can not only
make sure music from neighboring stages
don't bleed into one another but that
there are no dead zones throughout the
festival grounds that means that
wherever you stand you're still able to
hear music we used to walk into Arenas
and just draw a bunch of x's like oh put
a motor there put a motor there put a
motor there put a motor there and fly
them up to 40 feet and
um that should do it it was all
eyeballed when line arrays were released
Acoustics release software that allowed
you to determine down to a fraction of a
degree the angle between the boxes we
can now aim sound to a certain distance
and then have it taper off relatively
quickly we've gained the ability to
really cover specific areas we showed
Dave images from past festivals to see
how much they've changed here if you
look at this Behind These rainbow scrims
there is 90 boxes per side each of those
boxes is four foot high by four foot
wide that's huge and heavy takes a long
time to set up fast forward here's
Coachella 2011 also doing a Big Field
gig and we've gone from 90 speakers
aside to these tall slender line arrays
this was uh 2001 the first year that we
did it and here we can see the rat trap
rigs a system I designed that is four
deep Six Wide kind of an old school
system before the true line arrays came
into play so this is when we bought our
first vdos rig and there is the line
array so this is the festival's grown
and you can see that there's less PA or
seemingly less PA yet the volume and
coverage was actually louder now this
one here we've actually it looks bigger
it's actually two line array side by
side and that's my fault line arrays
should never be put side by side they
interfere with each other but I solved
it by not running the same signal into
both I actually have two Pas here one
for vocals and drums and another one for
guitar and bass they were completely
separate and that was apps absolutely
amazing and here is the first year we
got the new system this is a K1 system
so now we could hang 24 boxes deep
instead of 14. this was the largest
deployment of the sound system that it
ever existed in the world to date look
at the change in this year from those
drops and then video screen behind
two video screen there's guns and rows
look at that now here what they've done
is they've taken that sharp edge out of
the screen and made it smooth and that's
all high resolution video all the way
across if you really think about it we
want to hear sound we don't want to see
it if we could make the sound system
invisible we will have one we want to
just hear it and line arrays helped us
get a heck of a lot closer to that